guys our next guest knows a thing or two
about Tom Brady as his former teammate
he's earned four Super Bowl rings and
soon a spot in the Football Hall of Fame
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
man the myth the legend Rob Gronkowski
AKA grunk oh God
what's up guys what's up guys how'd you
just hungry
yeah
it's the first time I've seen it man uh
if you love Croc these would be looks
like a Big Mac Truck too you know
right I can tell by the White Walls in
the background that grunt is bored and
he wants to play football again look at
this man is doing nothing with him with
his goddamn time what's going on
hey all right now if Tom Brady calls you
to come out of retirement again do you
take the call I will 100 answer Tom
Brady's call and I will 100
that I miss them as well but I will 100
tell Tom while being extra nervous and
extra scared telling him that I am not
coming back to play football but I still
love you you were saying like that that
was a long way around
why not just say Tom go [ __ ] yourself
I'm enjoying myself yeah yeah that's
that's a good point I'm gonna say that
Tom go [ __ ] yourself
leave me alone that's right listen Tom I
was there when you had a good team you
take that pile of [ __ ] that you're
playing with and shove it up your ass
Tom I'm enjoying my retirement that's
what you say that's what you're saying
yeah what was your like main highlight
of 2022 you think oh my main highlight
was by my mom a crib wow nice 2022 you
did that huh yeah you've been making
money for a while
2022 is a year that you decided to do
that one huh been in the goddamn
football league for 15 Seasons yeah okay
15 seasons of legal money legal money
yes yes for 12 years yeah good luck man
that's that we're happy for your mom
thank you man all right what do you got
planned for holidays girl uh this year
I'm gonna probably just go to my
hometown Buffalo New York garage bike a
couple Christmas my nephews and
niece and uh go snowmobiling and skiing
for the holidays shout out to Buffalo
man shout out what's up man I hope they
didn't dug themselves out by now well I
know that's right that was the last one
that was a lot all right don't we had a
lot of snow inside uh listen Rock give
me this man um who's winning the Super
Bowl in February give me an honest pick
and don't try to throw Tom Brady in
there just because who's winning the
Super I'm not gonna throw them in there
but it's definitely not the eagles they
trashed what the [ __ ] you son of a dude
I'll go with the Buffalo Bills okay oh
that's a low blow cause you know I'm a
die hard Eagles fan you know that all
you have to do is say Eagles Eagles are
shooting but instead you chose the low
route you chose the low route and for
that for that my friend you and I we're
on the outs you hear me you have not
shown respect sir I let you win a Super
Bowl about four years ago because I'm a
nice guy first of all you didn't let me
win [ __ ] we took it yes I did it we took
that Super Bowl and if your favorite
quarterback if he didn't drop the
goddamn pass to himself you guys will be
in a different situation girl that's
right I don't forget anything yeah
you're such a crybaby you needed one or
else you'd still be crying all right
that's enough for this [ __ ] you know
what I can't wait to come over your
house
dirty hands all over those white ass
walls
give me my confidence
the [ __ ] up bro you just wait till I see
you in person get your ass over here
yeah I will be over there we're out of
here
happy holidays come on
thank you yeah my hands are dirty too
they're coming don't worry about double
hands that's right
we appreciate you love you guys